so for practice with expectation let's
calculate the expected number of heads
in n coin flips and just working
directly from the definition because we
have tools to do that
so we're imagining n independent flips
of a coin with bias pace of the coins
not might not be fair the probability of
heads is P it would be biased in favor
of heads if P is greater than 1/2 and
biased against heads if P is less than
1/2 and we want to know how many heads
are expected this is a basic question
that will come up again and again when
we look at random variables in
probability theory so what's the
expected number of heads well we already
know we've examined the binomial
distribution B and pay a b NP is telling
us how many heads there are and an
independent flips so we're asking about
the expectation of the binomial variable
b NP well let's look at the definition
the definition of that of b NP is it's
the sum over all the possible values of
being namely all the numbers from 0 to n
that's K of the probability of getting K
heads and this formula here is the
probability of getting hey K heads which
we've worked that previously and choose
K times P to the K 1 minus P to the N
minus K well let's introduce an
abbreviation a standard abbreviation
let's replace 1 minus P by Q where so P
plus Q equals 1 and they're both not
negative and between 0 and 1 and when I
express the expectation this way it
starts to look like something a little
bit familiar and our strategy is gonna
be to use the binomial theorem and then
the trick of differentiating it is gonna
wind up giving us a closed formula for
this expression for the expectation of
the binomial random variable so let's
remember the binomial theorem says that
the nth power of X plus y is the sum of
from k equals 0 to n of n choose K X to
the K Y to the N minus K and
if I differentiate this and what happens
is that on the left hand side if I
differentiate with respect to X I get X
plus y to the n minus 1 times n and if I
differentiate the right hand side let's
differentiate it term by term and
differentiating with respect to X is
going to turn this and choose K X to the
K Y to the N minus K into an X to the K
minus 1 times K term but I'd like to
keep the N and the the K here and the K
they're matching so that have to
differentiate after differentiating that
becomes an X to the K minus 1 let's
multiply it by X to make it X to the K
and of course I have to undo that
multiplication by dividing the whole
thing by 1 over X so by differentiating
the binomial formula we get the
following formula for this for some that
is starting to look just like the
expectation of BN paying 1 over X times
the sum from k equals 0 at 1 of K times
n choose K X to the K Y to the N minus K
well let's compare the two terms so
here's this term there's this one I'm
going to replace this line by the
formula for expectation of a binomial
random variable so this is what we're
trying to evaluate and I have this great
theorem you can see how they match up so
what I'm going to do is replace P and Q
replace x and Y in this general formula
that I got by differentiating the
binomial theorem with P and Q and what
happens so just plug in the P and Q now
the left-hand side P plus Q is 1 so the
left-hand side is B gonna become n and
this right-hand side now is exactly the
expectation of BN P this part of it
anyway so what I'm going to wind up with
is that n is equal to the expected time
the expectation of BN P in other words
the expectation of BN P is n times P and
that is the basic formula that we were
deriving by first principles
without using any general properties of
expectation just the definition of
expectation and the stuff that we had
already worked out in terms of the
binomial theorem